peu
[Musique]
voilà vous avez gagné votre nom face à
face sur la madame cunégonde ça passe
sur toi hein d'accord d'accord sur la
zone des alouettes je crois pas par
fabien 1
c'est ça madame lundi nous allons le
pauvre le plaisir de vous faire remettre
à transistor mos eisley remède à
transistor j'me non non non c'est bien
parce que ça mérite pas sa bande
non non bien
alors qui pour le suit à la paix dans
l'est pour le ni oui ni non pour ayew
s'est dit moi simplement je vais régler
c'est el ayoun place après le mois je le
rappelle merci bon il faut compte amène
à un machin moment de l'avènement du
coup je suis avec we made you me
souviens je suis avec la passe qu'il
sera là bien maintenant cher monsieur je
voudrais savoir un peu probable un
camion peut être par débit mise à bas
des chats je suis où je demande du céou
oui bon bien
je vais mettre à votre hauteur
voilà et oui
donc je commence sur la deux
rachel caméra 2 jean-paul l'inconnu
attendons j'ai d'abord l'indicatif
j'oublie ni oui ni non
excuse moi je demande 10 secondes
non mais
je vois
l'errance été
près d'une heure arrange il ya deux
diapos jeu game show
c'était pas mal grâce à de la terre
l'eau 3 et 3 10 yapo 3 et 3 bis après tu
me mets
musique1 musique et tu me rajoute le
synthétiseur bon et apprendre marque
caméra 2 c'est bon je suis donc c'est la
fin d'une imminent et ça va être ensuite
rutman le début de brad et moi vos yeux
bon le silence derrière messieurs s'il
vous plaît dès que j'ai dit merci à
monsieur 1
c'est qui c'est on a fini vous avez tenu
très bien deux minutes trente et une
minutes trente de crédit que vous donnez
pour nos concurrents tout à l'heure qui
n'ont plus maintenant douze minutes mais
seulement 10 minutes 30 à tenir
eh bien monsieur merci rejoignez nos
invités continuent à jouer avec nous
nous passons non non je ne bouge pas que
nous serons là il rejoint nos invités
nous allons maintenant passer un autre
jeu vous allez voir avec nous ce jeu
s'appelle par est alors qui je le dis
moi tu saches et paraissent bon ou ce
jeu s'appelle prêter mois se nomme
prêter - vos yeux dès que j'ai dit ça
dès que la musique du générique retente
vous ruer sur ce fauteuil et vous leur
tirez pas rouge rutman s'il te plaît
[ __ ] je te dise tout de suite j
secondes je rends démarre sur la une
dans le trot donc de ton côté
alors au troisième fauteuil rentrer tout
de suite
et vous alors toi dégage pas y prendre
une photo et monsieur fait le guide suis
à tout contrat mais nous touchons des
pompes par l'apu par là par la ram et
vous sortez c'est fini ça vient d'accord
d'accord
2 comme d'habitude en france le
téléphone ne marche pas donc vous voyez
en quoi ce délire est certain c'est là
qu'une avance alors c'est un message à
sa lumière l'impression que c'est bon je
sais branché sur la maison aujourd'hui
ce que sans ça soit directement à
d'accord mais nous sommes d'accord car
autrement ce sera sans passer par le 5
direct bon alors là je pense très sûre
d'elle même qui le dit et bouger de
crise les moyens y a personne dans les
cas s'il ya exposé jacques hebinger
envie de te prendre carrément ici entre
2 qu'est ce que ça donne chez toi
ronfler reflète j'explique qu'est ce que
ça donne pour toi vas voir lui entre eux
deux
reprendre la même menace ensuite elle a
deux tubes y en a deux fils sont partis
joyeux pour des courses lointaines
capitaine voyer que jean-paul ne
comprendra pas cette belle peau ici que
jean-paul ne prendra pas cette crise en
effet ces téléphones permettent
d'entendre de la musique manouche et la
joie mais ne compte que nous permettent
pas d'en comprendre le sens monsieur
je
tout n'est pas rose
je voyais chine 1,3 en mars
vous avez numéro 7
prometic mois si monsieur roux
l'accrocher à s'il vous plaît monsieur
très gentil entendra bien visible sous
lé jeu chose mais je serai ici et ceux
ci
[Musique]
voilà monsieur raymond merci beaucoup
madame pulicani
man
sa vie
faire l'appel à liège
m
c'est l'ailé
à la jeunesse
les permis
voilà ma musique
g
messieurs parti j'aurais une ou deux
personnes soir là ici mais je suis au
premier rang sera très bien madame au
premier rang là aussi madame un peu
derrière
oui c ou d et encore une personne 2g pas
pardon se termine non monsieur ici ici
c'est monsieur adhérents la voir la
deuxième chaîne me demandait de créer
une émission de jeu si possible d'un
style nouveau
en six semaines de toute une équipe de
techniciens décorateurs ont mis au point
finalement le la salle un peu
particulière dans laquelle vous vous
trouvez aujourd'hui et nous allons
essayer des jeux un petit peu
particulier avec vous tout à l'heure
certains non merci ça va vous les posez
là mon vieux même seul suffit comme ça
va vous mettez un micro lecteur pour
certains vont peut-être être des ratages
parfait d'autres vont peut-être bien
marché nous ne le savons absolument pas
car seul le verdict du public peut nous
fixer dans les jeux voilà 20 ans 30 ans
bientôt ce ne sont des jeux et pour
autant à chaque fois est une aventure à
chaque fois on ne sait pas si ça va ou
ça ne va pas marcher
d'ailleurs ce qui est amusant de notre
métier ont une certaine mesure ce que
rien n'est sûr rien n'est certain
c'est encore un domaine où l'ordinateur
ne peut rien nous espérons que ça durera
encore longtemps
bien sûr ce soir
cette émission n'est pas fait pour
passer sur l'antenne je le dis tout de
suite elle restera en petit comité
pour autant je vous demande d'avoir le
même comportement que si cette émission
était en direct sur l'antenne d'oublier
complètement qu'il est enregistré en
vase clos et de toute façon bien sûr
vous serez est prioritaire
i la gentillesse de bien vouloir subir
ce test vous serez prioritaire pour les
émissions définitif qui verront le jour
à partir du 5 nov
il y aura un autre public demain soir
qui va à nouveau faire une émission test
comme celle de ce soir sera un peu
modifié par rapport à ce que nous aurons
appris ce soir
et ces deux publics donc ses cent
personnes environ que représentent ces
deux émissions tests seront réinviter
bien sûr immédiatement dans les autres
émissions à leur compte
aujourd'hui malgré tout nous aurons le
plaisir de vous distinguer quelques
petits cadeaux qu'ils n'auront pas de
comparaison malgré tout avec les cadeaux
qu'on distribueront dans les vraies
émissions mais pour autant il faut tout
de suite insisté sur le fait que cette
émission n'est pas basé sur des gains
importants je dis tout de suite ça n'a
strictement rien à voir avec pas une
seconde à perdre avec la tête et les
jambes et ses terrains le gain le plus
important c'est une télévision couleur
ce n'est pas négligeable enfin briller
ça m'a quand même pas de comparaison
avec les millions de gagner d'autres
jeux et le gars le plus courant c'est un
transistor un but ben ya également une
rente de 50 mille francs par semaine qui
tombe dans l'escarcelle d'un certain
nombre de candidats et je vais vous
expliquer comment pourrait-on je vais
vous donner si vous voulez très
rapidement fin nous c'est le complice un
aperçu rapide de ce que va être la vie
si je vois silence derrière s'il vous
plaît c'est une succession de jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
les entrées sans frappe et oui il nous
arrive si régulièrement d'entrée sans
frapper chez vous que c'était la moindre
des choses de vous proposer d'entrer
sans frapper chez en effet pendant une
heure avec nous ses amis qui nous ont
fait le plaisir d'être réunis ici
aujourd'hui nous allons essayer de jouer
nous allons essayer de nous distraire de
nous divertir tout de suite
nous n'allons pas bien entendu vous
faire attendre plus longtemps voici le
premier jeu il s'agit de jeux de mains
non monsieur vous allez essayer de vous
faire comprendre tour à tour un certain
nombre de choses d'objets de métier
uniquement par gestes
vous aurez un capital temps de cinq
minutes bien eux
nous allons commencer on dit veut
commencer est-ce que c'est monsieur
mambé monsieur non pas galant alors
attention le chrono à partir plus vite
vous aurez trouvé ce que monsieur mime
plus vite j'arrive à le peindre dès que
vous avez compris pour me dire que vous
voulez me donner la réponse vous devez
louer un beau jared d'accord j'arrête de
connard salue ses larmes
[Musique]
oh
à
qui
[Musique]